ab sofort kann sich jeder seinen eigenen
roboter bauen alles was man dazu braucht
es einen 3d drucker und die gibt es ja
inzwischen schon für übersichtliches
geld und etwas geschick und zwar
wirklich nicht viel
beim roboter in mode sind die baupläne
als open hardware offen für alle
was wirklich hinter diesem projekt
steckt was der roboter alles kann und
noch weitere spannende infos mehr jetzt
bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
ein thema aus der klicks und community
auf whatsapp und in anderen ländern
vielen dank dafür wie er dahin kommt
dass er vater am ende des videos es ist
wirklich verrückt was manchmal und vor
allem wo und wie technologiesprünge
stattfinden wer hätte gedacht dass
amerikas autoindustrie durch den bau von
elektroautos von tesla wiederbelebt wird
aber der roboter in hof der ist
faszinierend und unheimlich zugleich
er ist so groß wie ein mensch und hat
genau wie wir zwar nur die beine fehlen
aber dafür hat der augen in den kameras
die objekte und menschen verfolgen
können und auch gesten erkennt der
roboter und zwar durch eine kinect in
seinem bus kommt alles mit ganz
einfachen mitteln und man kann sich auch
mit ihm unterhalten spricht man in
anderen nennt ihm zahlen macht er die
entsprechende programmierte g stone
bestätigt dann beispielsweise news.at
land noch relativ simpel aber immerhin
möglich machen das die spracherkennung
lautsprecher und mikrofone mit denen in
move ausgestattet ist aber jetzt noch
mal von vorne entwickelt wurde der
roboter von dem französischen bildhauer
also einem bildhauer niek einem fachmann
delonge war der ursprünglich eigentlich
nur eine handprothese entwerfen wollte
mit seinem einen 3d drucker stellte er
die hand her und fand dann aber kein
ende er wollte sein projekt mit anderen
leuten teilen und veröffentlichte die
konstruktions dateien für seinen roboter
auf singles einer plattform für open
source hardware
die reaktionen waren überwältigend und
logen war machte weiter er nutzte einen
microcontroller bord mit dem sich die
finger mit hilfe von motoren
kontrollieren lassen und so ging es
weiter mit schultern bizeps und so
weiter bis in mustern so weit fertig war
oberkörper kopf arme hände nur die beine
fehlen wie gesagt dafür können aber die
arme von jedem pc aus angesteuert werden
insgesamt hat der roboter mittlerweile
26 servomotor die seine bewegungen
steuern ansonsten läuft über eine 6 volt
batterie ja sein erfinder hatte
kurioserweise keine ahnung er war ja
bildhauer von elektronik oder
robotertechnik dazu londoner selbst ich
musste mich mit allen möglichen
anforderungen auseinandersetzen aber die
elektronik habe ich immer vernachlässigt
weil das nicht meine
starke war ich war wirklich von der
elektronik eingeschüchtert
da ich nichts über sie wusste ja den
einen innenhof den gibt es übrigens
nicht denn das ist ja die idee von open
source jeder kann sich seine eigene
roboter version basteln alle quellcodes
konstruktions vorlagen und pro design
prozesse werden offengelegt lounge war
hat nur eine sache bezüglich imhof
geregelt er darf nicht kommerziell
genutzt werden
dafür fehlt die lizenz privat aber kann
jeder der einen 3d drucker hat den
roboter nachbau notwendig dafür ist ein
12 x 12 x 12 cm großer baum die ganze
wasser seien kostenlos wenn dann etwa
1000 euro
zehn bis hundertmal weniger als andere
roboter dieser art dazu kommen natürlich
noch die kosten für 3d drucker und gelb
ist wichtig dass die sache weiterhin als
open source projekt läuft ich weiß zwar
nicht ob roboter die von uns erschaffen
werden unser leben kraft verbessern
werden aber sie werden uns in
irgendeiner art und weise erweitern wie
werkzeuge eben ich glaube daran dass
roboter saß sein werden was wir menschen
wollen und nicht mehr
ja da gibt es ja auch verschiedene
meinungen wir haben darüber berichtet
dafür soll in move demnächst auch noch
beine bekommen und das wird sein gewicht
von derzeit 17 kilogramm normal hin
möchte ihm langfristig auch das laufen
ermöglichen und es geht noch weiter
forschungsteams weltweit tüfteln ja
daran die beziehungen zwischen robotern
und menschen zu verbessern und da helfen
solche open source projekt natürlich
auch das sind alles riesige schritte man
darf das nicht unterschätzen wenn die
hürden so niedrig gesetzt werden um sich
selber ein roboter bauen zu können
das ist schon der wahnsinn ja und die
forschungsteams die arbeiten
beispielsweise dann an
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen und
charaktereigenschaften die den robotern
verliehen werden sollen sie sollen dann
in der lage sein beziehungen zwischen
menschen zu verstehen was es wiederum
möglich machen würde dass die roboter
selbst eine beziehung zu menschen
aufbauen können also das sind schon
gespenstische perspektiven ja aber heute
fehlen den robotern noch diese
menschlichen charakteristika wenn ihr
kein video zur entwicklung von robotern
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann hättet mich beim wort app und in
anderen messengern nur dann verpasst er
kein video denn die abo box auf youtube
das wisst ihr ja dieses ziemlich rücken
und über die messenger da erfahrt ihr
von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren das geht hier dann erfahrt
ihr das neueste aus der social media
welt aber nicht wenn er hier drauf
klickt die genau glocke vergessen und c
hier geht es weiter dafür auch darauf
blicken roboter sofia will menschheit
zerstören
bis dann bleibt dran